(man) The sharks are back
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
It's the only one
of its kind.
We can't keep up
with our own demand.
Fantastic.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest using
their own money,
and they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
You're valuing this business
at over a million bucks.
You haven't heard a word
about the business.
He's acting like a greedy pig.
Pipe down, little man.
Ooh.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
(speaks indistinctly)
You better be working
16 hours a day on our business.
Sorry. What did you say?
Ay, yi yi.
It's sink...
I'm surprised you haven't
been slaughtered yet.
Or swim.
Can I get a "whoop"?
whoop.
Whoop.
Boop, boop, boop, boop,
boop, boop.
(Mark and Kevin)
Beep-Beep-Beep.
Beep.
You're a strange cat.
Who are the sharks?
They're self-Made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
went from working
as a waitress in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real estate empire.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
Who grew his homemade
clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪♪
(ship horn blows)
I'm Jim Tselikis...
and I'm Sabin Lomac.
And we are cousins
from Portland, Maine.
And together, we are
Cousins Maine Lobster.
Best part about growing up
in Maine is the family,
being by the water,
but most importantly,
the lobster.
Maine lobster is
the most tender, succulent meat
you'll ever have.
We are from Maine But currently
living in Los Angeles.
Who wants
some fresh Maine lobster?!
in Los Angeles right now, there
is a food truck phenomenon,
and we want to combine
the two best industries going.
Hot meat coming right up.
Right now,
our business is booming.
We have lines
around the block
and we can't service
the people.
We need another truck
and we can't do it on our own,
so it's so important for us
to get this investment
from the sharks.
Whoo-Hoo-Hoo-Hoo!
♪♪♪
Hi, sharks. My name is
Sabin Lomac.
And I am his Younger cousin
Jim Tselikis.
And together, we are
Cousins Maine Lobster.
Sharks, we're here seeking
$55,000
in exchange
for 5% of our company.
Sharks, picture this.
It's summertime in Maine.
Both locals and tourists alike
are in line
at Maine's iconic
lobster shack.
They're standing alongside
the Atlantic ocean,
smelling that salty air.
Most importantly, they are
eagerly awaiting the chance,
the opportunity,
to sink their teeth
into Maine's signature dish--
The lobster roll.
Sharks,
at cousins Maine lobster,
we bring
the Maine lobster experience
to Southern California,
and we do it via our amazing
gourmet lobster shack on wheels.
We get our lobsters from shore
to door in less than 24 hours.
So you know what that means,
Barbara?
Next time you're eating
with the cousins,
you are having
the freshest fare possible.
Here's the thing.
Right now, we need to add
another truck or two
because frankly, we can't
keep up with our own demand,
and that's where
you come in.
We would love for one of you
to join our family business
and become the third cousin.
Can we try it?
Absolutely.
You certainly can. Absolutely.
All right! With that buildup...
Yeah.
How did you get the lobster
from Maine to California?
Barbara, stop.
Let's try it first.
Oh, I can eat and listen
at the same time.
We ship everything fresh
every day, including the bread,
from Maine to Los Angeles.
So you have two different types
of our rolls.
One of them is the signature
Maine lobster roll.
(Robert) Oh!
Uh, split-top bun,
fresh Maine lobster meat,
a little bit of mayonnaise.
And then you have
our connecticut roll.
That has
the little lemon on top.
This is fantastic.
Mmm!
I'm glad you enjoy it.
You know, and that's--and that's
the freshest of Maine.
That's what we grew up with,
we were privy to all the time.
Is your supplier a cousin?
Great question.
Maine lobster industry is not
something you can call into
And, uh, you know,
get the access and the pricing
that we have.
You grow up with it.
But you're saying
you're the only one
who can get this?
So they are your family?
They're not family, but we--
the Mainers. The roots.
We grew up with them.
Be careful with that.
There are multiple suppliers
of lobster meat in Maine.
of lobsters,
but it just depends on
the pricing
that you're getting it at
in order to ship it wholesale
across the country.
And that's where we come in
because--
Because This is where
I'm getting a little concerned,
guys.
$55,000 for 5%.
Basically, you wanna buy
another truck with my $55,000.
You're valuing this business
at over a million bucks.
$1.1 million.
You haven't heard a word
about the business.
(Robert) Yeah, you don't know.
I know the business already,
Mark.
So what are you worried
about the valuation?
They may have ten trucks,
so you--How many trucks
do you have?
Right now,
we have one truck.
Ooh.
$150,000 of sales.
We've been open two months.
Two months?
One truck.
With one truck.
Where do you park the truck?
Literally all over
Los Angeles.
But how do people find you?
Twitter, web site,
social media.
Social media.
Okay, then let me ask you this.
Let's say I want to be
in the lobster business.
Mr. Wonderful's lobster, okay?
Mm-hmm.
(laughs)
Why don't I just go get
a couple of guys
with flip-flops on,
call up somebody in Maine
and say,
"I've got money.
You've got lobsters"...
Mm-hmm.
And do this whole thing
myself?
Why are you worth
$1.1 million?
We--
Come back with an answer
that maybe you won't
get sliced up into bun with.
You can start your own truck
and you can hire your own staff.
But what you can't do
is what you just said
and call up on the phone
to Maine.
They don't do business
with other guys outside.
It's not--It's not like that.
So you're the only guys--
'cause you've only even been
in business two months--
These guys only deal
with you now because they--
they haven't been in business
the last 50 years?
No, no, no. Of course.
You know, they have.
And--And we--
You are very greedy crustaceans,
both of you.
(chuckles nervously)
Jim, I don't think anybody's
buying your story.
I am.
It's not--It's not greed.
You haven't gotten into
the economics per truck.
Right.
You haven't talked about
seasonality.
any other cost issues
that might come along.
Right. So we're locked into
our pricing,
and typically, prices will rise.
With our connections and what
we have with our supplier,
we're locked in.
What we're paying right now,
we're gonna be paying
in the winter.
So what are you paying
right now on a--
what's the average?
The traditional lobster roll,
we price at $13.
What's your cost on that?
$5.85.
Guys,
I asked you the question
about the economics
of the truck.
Mm-hmm.
So please,
somebody who might invest,
tell me what the economics are
per truck.
Okay, so we'll start with,
how much is a purchase?
You buy it for roughly--
Ours was $65,000.
Okay.
Monthly overhead
with our employees--
$20,000.
Per truck or...
per truck.
Okay.
(Daymond and Robert) a month?
A month. Mm-Hmm.
Okay, so 20k per month
per truck.
If you have
more than one truck,
does it get advertised
across the truck?
The overhead would actually
go down a little
because we've hired
a general manager.
You're not the general manager
in this little business?
(stammers)
Well--Well--Well,
there's a reason why that,
is because when we got
into this business,
we knew a lot about lobster.
We knew a lot about
the service industry.
We didn't know a lot about
the trucking business.
How did you get
into the business?
How'd you get from Maine to...
(Jim) Great question. We--
Bring your lobster
over here to California?
So we both grew up in Maine.
And, uh, he's been out here
about eight years--Sabin has.
What brought you out here
eight years ago?
I used to do a lot of acting,
and I translated
that into, uh, real estate
and I've become successful
at real estate.
It allowed me to--to save
some money and do well.
He's still a great actor.
He's acting like a greedy pig,
asking for $55,000 for 5%.
No. No. Honestly, we're not
trying to be greedy.
What is in it for us?
To be a part of this family,
just like we need you.
And to make money.
Guys, these guys are talking
all kinds of nonsense.
I had asked you what
the economics of the truck were.
You know what?
Because you thought it was
more important
to talk about all the nonsense
and couldn't see through
the nonsense...
that's not fair, Mark.
I'm out.
Oh, my god, mark. What?
Yeah, what's that about?
(Kevin) He was never in.
It was a simple question.
You guys went--
(Robert) wow.
They weren't ignoring you.
You're starting to act
like Daymond, like a baby.
(laughs)
OHH!
So why don't you--
So why don't you let it go?
No, 'cause I--
I asked it twice. I asked
the question twice, not once.
So, Barb, are you gonna
write 'em a check?
You know what?
I am gonna write them a check.
Yes, I am, big mouth.
Pipe down, little man.
Let's go. Let's go.
(Robert) All right,
write 'em a check.
Barb, just 'cause
you're an old crab
doesn't mean you should get
into the lobster business.
Whoa! Daymond!
Are there other competitors?
There--Sometimes there are
two other competitors,
to our knowledge.
Are they selling
Maine lobster like you?
Of course they are.
There's none in Texas.
Who cares? Who cares where
the lobsters come from?
(laughs)
Guys, here. Help me,
'cause--'cause I like the idea.
Yes.
And I know this is very hot
and people are loving this.
Help me get to the $1 million--
$1.1 million valuation.
It's so high.
It's so ridiculous. Yes.
It's outrageous,
what you're asking for.
Okay.
I can't take anymore.
For the sake of lobsters
who are still alive, I'm out.
Okay.
So the bottom feeder's out.
(Jim chuckles)
to--to your point,
we are first month, $65,000.
The second month, $85,000.
Fantastic.
We're getting calls
'round the clock.
We have to turn down
catering events.
We're getting--
We're turning down business.
I'm gonna tell you
the honest truth.
Maybe you don't know this
about my history.
I was a commercial fisherman
for a year...
Yep.
And I worked
in a red lobster for ages.
(Jim and Sabin)
We did know that.
All right?
So I do understand
a little bit of the market.
You're making everything--
The fact that you just have
a contact in Maine?
I mean, one of the only places
you can buy lobster,
which everybody
buys lobster from.
So for $55,000,
you are offering 5%.
That is crazy.
You're kinda like
halfway in a body bag
without the zipper pulled up
right now.
Give me your best offer.
♪♪♪
Two sharks are out.
Daymond is interested,
but by asking for $55,000
for only 5% of their company,
he feels Sabin and Jim have
grossly overvalued
their company
and has given them
one last chance
to make him a better offer.
Give me your best offer.
I mean...
I would feel
really comfortable
right around the 7% to 8%.
(sharks laugh)
You know what?
You're a very good actor.
You said that
with a straight face.
So, uh, I'm out.
Okay. Okay.
Thank you.
Ay, yi yi.
I really like you guys.
I think you're hustlers.
I like to invest in people
that like to get up every day
and work their Butts off.
And that's what we're doing.
Right.
So I'll give you the $55,000,
but I want 25%.
Okay.
Is that an offer
you would entertain?
I do not think so, no.
(speaks indistinctly)
Can we hear Barbara's?
Well, I'm going
to offer you your $55,000,
and--But for
that amount of money,
I would like to have 17%
of your business.
17%.
And you--And you know why?
'cause 17's my lucky number.
Sabin, I'm really good at
building businesses quickly.
Hey, I think the way
I'm gonna get my money back
is by having more trucks
on the street.
So let me change my offer.
I'll give you $100,000, 'cause
I think you need more money
to get more trucks
on the street.
So $100,000 for 25%.
You don't need that much money,
do you?
(sighs)
You've got one offer
for $100,000 for 25%,
and Barbara, who likes
the lucky number 17...
who's randomly pulling
your value out of the air,
which she often does.
What are you going to do?
Our last question--
Strategies? Thoughts that
you guys might have?
Great question.
The best thing
I could do for you
which this guy cannot do is,
I am a genius marketer.
I am. I have it in my bones,
in my blood.
It always works.
I'm never wrong.
I think your truck is terrible.
Forgive me. Don't feel offended.
It's not a personal thing.
I can't believe
your two handsome faces
aren't side-By-Side
in caricatures as the cousins.
I don't even like the fact that
"Cousins Maine lobster"
doesn't say
"Cousins fresh Maine lobster."
It should have "fresh" in there.
Let me get my hands
in that business
and I'll tell you
everything wrong with it.
I have to agree
with Krusty krab over there.
She has some
great marketing ideas.
All right, let--Let me answer
that question.
Uh, you gotta be kidding me.
There's a reason I'm up here.
I-I don't need to prove
what I can do...
But they asked you.
To you.
You wanna go in
and change their business?
Do you need a job, Barbara?
I wanna help them.
Go ahead.
My offer's off the table.
No, I help every entrepreneur
I'm in business with.
You're left with Barbara.
I have a job.
Robert, you're out?
I'm out.
That was the butter and lemon
right there.
Okay, So, uh...
Barbara,
would you consider 12%?
(chuckles)
(mouths word)
Okay.
Why are you guys holding on
so tightly to the equity?
Because it's--It's--
It's our baby. It's--
80% of a watermelon is
better than 100% of a grape.
Mark, you said, "5% of something
is better than 0% of nothing"
in the past.
You know what I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna meet you halfway.
The $55,000 for 15%.
Halfway between
the 12% and the 17%.
J.T.?
Let's go.
Barbara,
welcome to the family.
(Jim laughs)
Thank you.
Come on over here.
Come bring it in.
Baby, I'm coming.
Have you ever had
a lobster sandwich?
I'm coming!
(Robert) WHOA!
It's a family show, guys!
All right!
Get on in here.
Give me a hug!
(laughs)
Thank you.
Thanks, guys.
Guys, I was wrong.
You came to make a deal.
Congrats.
Thank you.
By the way,
their stuff is incredible.
Let's see 'em out, baby.
(laughs)
the future with Barbara--
Sky's the limit.
And, uh, I think
she likes us, Jim.
I think she likes you
a little more than me.
Oh, well, typically.
That's usually how it goes.
Yeah, but--But either way,
we feel really, really good
about it
and, uh, we're excited.
♪♪♪
Last season,
we watched Dallas Robinson
and Mike Buonomo
Seal the deal
with Mark Cuban...
(man) Little longer.
(Daymond) ohh!
For their lip balm brand
Kisstixx.
Thanks, guys.
Let's see what
they're up to now.
♪♪♪
Since airing on "Shark Tank,
we've sold over $1 million
worth of Kisstixx products.
We've added
three new product lines,
we're already in
over a thousand retailers,
and we're set to launch in
Kmart, Supervalu, Winn-Dixie,
Party City, and Icing
by the end of the year.
Hello?
Hey, it's mark.
Hey, Mark.
How's it going? It's Dallas?
We never thought
at 25 years old
we'd be business partners
with Mark Cuban.
We got some big chains
coming on board.
Just kinda want to get
your take.
We don't want to drown
an opportunity.
You can't try to do
too much, too soon.
(Mike) he's lived up
to everything
that he said
that he would do.
He's been an awesome mentor
for us.
Because we have Mark Cuban
and his financial backing,
there's no limit
to the speed of our growth.
Next up is Zach Crain,
who wants to put an end
to moist handshakes forever.
♪♪♪
(sharks laugh)
(trills)
(makes whoosh sounds)
(Robert) Whoa.
Hoo! Well...
(clears throat)
first off, you guys are
looking beautiful.
Thank you.
Uh, my name is Zach.
I invented this thing
called a freaker.
And I'm here today
looking for
a $200,000 investment
in exchange for a 10% equity
in my company freaker usa.
So...
♪ dun, dun, dun, dun, dun ♪
This is a freaker.
We have over 35 designs.
We add characters and
personalities to all of them.
The freaker's function
is that it has magical fibers
in it to make it stretch
so they can fit every beverage
in the world.
♪ Doo, doo, doo, doo, doo ♪
so you can put it
on your morning beer
if you wanted to.
♪ Boop-Boop-a-doop-a-Doop
boop-Boop ♪
♪ boom-Boom-a-Doom ♪
hmm?
(laughs)
All right?
And the freaker will fit every
water bottle in the world.
That is pretty crazy.
Every water bottle.
For my last trick, I'm gonna put
This little tiny freaker
on This huge wine bottle.
As you can see,
there are no wires attached.
Doo, doo, doo, doo, doo.
Uh, there's nothing
up my sleeve.
Nothing in my beard.
Daymond, you wanna check
my beard to make sure?
No, I'm good.
You're good? All right.
Can I get a "whoop"?
(sharks) whoop.
Robert, I love you.
Love you, man.
All right. ♪ Doo, doo-Doo
doo-Doo doo-Doo-Doo ♪
ooh!
Uh, without any further ado,
I have a little video
to show you guys,
um, more about it.
Hope you enjoy. Here we go.
Doo-Doo-Doo-Doo!
Boop! Now.
(man) This is the birth
of freaker usa.
(Zach) Living in a car,
traveling,
found a new home
in wilmington, north Carolina,
invited to a stitch 'n bitch
and learned to knit
a beer koozie.
Horrible knitter But wanted to
give them to all my friends.
Found old sweaters,
cut them up,
sewed them into beer koozies,
started feeling bad
about destroying
too many sexy sweaters,
ate pancakes, felt better,
found a small
mom-and-Pop hosiery mill
in Troy, north Carolina,
communicated through
song and dance.
Yay, they program robots
to spit out freakers.
Whew! Formed a team,
launched a web site,
made a bunch
of crazy marketing videos,
battled gandalf,
danced on a fire hydrant,
turned a box truck
into a house,
drove around the country
throwing
grilled cheese parties,
blew up some trade shows,
went on "Shark Tank,"
got a huge investment
for a small equity share,
stopped all bottles
from WETTING moist handshakes
in the world.
Yay, I'm freakin' excited.
Can I get a whoop?
Whoop! Whoop! (laughs)
You're a strange cat.
Oh, I've got--I've got some
freakers for you guys,
before I forget.
Here we go.
Awesome.
Zach, is this
is actual package?
Um, this is the package.
This just--
Um, these are the first freakers
that are packaged this way.
Thanks, Zach.
Yeah.
Zach, I hate to bring it
down to money,
but I always do.
Mm-hmm. What do you got?
Uh, $200,000 for 10%
is telling me
that you think
your freaker business
is worth $2 million.
Now I'm a believer.
I'm a believer, baby.
I'm gonna make you believe.
So why don't you tell me what
your sales are in the last year?
In the last year--We've only
been out for 13 months.
Uh, we're about $320,000.
Whoa!
(Kevin) So you're not so crazy.
You're making money.
Where are they--
Where are you selling them?
Uh, we have them in
about... 200 stores.
We've got
a japanese distributor,
a canadian distributor.
So--So, uh, this is not
a-a new idea.
Why is it, uh,
doing so well?
It is a new idea on the concept
that it's one drink insulator
that'll stretch
and fit everything.
No, I've seen it in lycra
and spandex and a few--
We have a patent on it.
Issued?
Yes.
What's your cost
per freaker?
Right about a dollar,
little under a dollar.
And what's
your wholesale cost?
Uh, wholesale starts at $4,
and suggested retail's
$8 to $10.
Doo-Doo-Doo-Doo-Doo-Doo-Doo.
Zach, I have
one more question.
Uh-Huh?
Why do you keep making
those noises?
(all laugh)
'cause it's cool.
(laughs)
So, Zach, I get
the whole lifestyle thing.
I buy into that.
Mm-hmm.
It's a brand builder.
The "doo-Doo-Doo-Doo"--
I love it all.
(laughs)
Now let's talk about
what your business
is really worth.
Let's say you're gonna do
$320,000 in the last--
Just over 11 months,
you said, right?
Uh, yeah.
So let's annualize that.
You're making about 15%
to the bottom line
before you pay tax--
Approximately.
Uh-huh.
You're worth somewhere between
350,000 and 400,000 bucks.
That's it.
Okay.
So I think I need 50%.
That would be
a reasonable valuation.
Yeah.
What do you say to that?
Um, I'd probably make some beeps
at ya and... (chuckles)
(all laugh)
Well, I'm just saying,
while we're beeping...
Yeah. Yeah.
Um, I-I wouldn't--I wouldn't
entertain it seriously.
Okay, Zach, baby.
Beep-Beep-Beep.
(laughs)
I'm out.
Okay.
Another cool thing
that we didn't touch on,
on the video,
there was a box truck
that we turned into a house
and we drove around the country,
throwing grilled cheese parties.
It's one of
our forms of marketing.
But isn't that kind of
the challenge, right?
I-I think it's cool.
You go around
to all the festivals.
You guys can set up at--
Huh? Not festivals.
You don't go to festivals at all
and set up?
Not right now. I don't really
like festivals, no.
Okay--
You don't like festivals?
(chuckles)
No.
(Barbara laughs)
(Robert laughs)
You seem perfect
for festivals.
I seem that way. I'm not--
I'm not much of a festival guy.
Really?
No.
What do you do
in your off time?
I get up early, usually go to
the river, walk dogs.
Let me tell you. How you valued
the company, it's nutsy.
On that basis alone,
although I love you,
I'm out.
Okay.
I love you, too, Barbara.
I love you, too.
I get the entire brand.
Yeah.
But there's no beeping way...
(laughs)
You're worth $2 million today.
Well, uh, there obviously--
I feel like there must be
some, like,
missing on your guys' part
of where I'm at
if you're not getting
even close to that.
Look, I like you, Zach...
Yeah.
But, you know, it's--It's--
It's--It's hard.
I-I can promise you,
you'd be into it.
I-I could say in six months,
you're gonna be like...
(high-Pitched voice)
man, what was I thinking?
Oh, Zach, you know what?
I gotta be honest with you.
When I'm not up here,
I'm dressed like you
and hanging out
and dancing everywhere.
We could have some, like,
umbrella drinks
and we'd kick it back...
(laughs)
Holler at some girls?
I'm out.
All right, Robert.
So, Zach, uh, you know,
I have to be passionate
about everything I invest in...
Yeah.
And I'm just not feeling
that way about this.
I'm out.
Okay. All right, you got
some words of wisdom?
You know, the reality is,
your margin's great.
The opportunity for branding
and putting a mavs logo
or whatever logo,
the incremental cost
is probably minimal.
So there's some
unique opportunities there.
But if I had to listen to,
"beep-Beep-Beep! Hey, Mark.
Beep-Beep-Beep-Beep!
What's up?"
(trills)
"beep-Beep-Beep!"
I'd shoot myself. I'm out.
Now we need to hear the beeping
of you backing up.
Boop, boop, boop,
boop, boop.
Beep! Beep!
All right. Love you, guys.
Boom-Boom-Boom-Boom-Boom.
Boom-Boom-Boom-Boom.
Mark, I thought you were in
for sure at the end.
Hell, no!
I-I love his technique. I'm-a do
that at my next meeting.
(trills)
what it was like
in the Shark Tank?
It was like,
beep, beep, beep, beep.
Beep!
Ah! (laughs)
♪♪♪
Next in are Tania Patruno
and NFL running back
Brandon Jacobs.
Hi. My name is
Tania Patruno...
and I'm 2-Time super Bowl
champion Brandon Jacobs.
And my company is PRO-NRG.
I'm here seeking $250,000
in exchange for 15% equity.
PRO-NRG is a unique
protein-Infused flavored water.
It's all-Natural
and great-Tasting,
with no fat, no caffeine,
and no sugar.
In just one 4-Ounce bottle,
there are 15 Grams
of whey protein,
essential vitamins,
and an energy blend.
It's balanced no matter
how active your lives are.
I didn't get to where I am
by playing a half a game.
I got to where I am
by playing a whole game
at a very, very high level,
and PRO-NRG has done that
for me.
I was overweight,
and like many people,
I bought in to all
the products and gimmicks
that claimed
to melt the weight off.
The truth is, I was frustrated
with the results,
so I set out to create
my own answer
and I brought it down
to the basics--
Rehydrate, replenish,
refresh.
I hustled my way
through doors
and I got PRO-NRG
into over 3,000 stores
in the New York area.
Wow.
Sharks, I need your investments
to fill my purchase orders
and propel PRO-NRG
onto the national market.
I'd like for you each
to have a try
so you can really experience
what PRO-NRG will do for you.
(groans) Oh.
Wow. What...
why does it taste so bad?
Taste so bad?
Yeah.
It tastes chemical-y.
I don't think it's bad
at all.
You ever taste
protein products?
No.
That's--there it is.
That's the difference, yeah.
Believe me, this is something
that tastes right.
Tania, what am I actually
buying here?
Do I get a boost?
Am I trying to get jacked up?
Or am I trying
to lose weight?
It's the only one
of its kind.
PRO-NRG simplifies
what your body needs.
Is this like a gatorade
or like a red Bull?
No.
It's not either one--
Either one of those.
Is it a weight loss product?
These guys have never
been in a gym,
so they--they don't quite
understand.
This is a complement
to a workout.
You wanna rehydrate
and you also want protein
to rebuild your muscles.
But, mark, shouldn't pro-"nurg"
Tell me that?
It's pro-"energy."
Pro-"n.R.G." (chuckles)
"n.R.G."
Okay. Whatever.
It's actually a great name.
Pro-"nurg"?
no, PRO-NRG.
Listen,
it's all fun and games
till Brandon comes over there
and crack your head open.
Nah, I'm--I'm not--I'm not
really... (speaks indistinctly)
he's not gonna...
then I will give you
the money--
I will give you
the money for that!
Oh, really?
Yeah, baby.
(sharks laugh)
put the ring on, too,
when you do it.
(chuckles) okay.
Brandon, you're obviously
a businessman.
So why do you guys need
the capital?
To get a 2-Time
super bowl champion
as part of my team--
You know,
I brought Brandon on,
but I'm not looking for him
to be an investor.
You guys are business--
Businessmen.
Why--Why isn't he
an investor?
Because I am an endorser.
Who do you play for?
San Francisco 49ers.
And what position
do you play?
Running back.
Played the last seven years with
the 2-Time super Bowl champion
New York giants.
I don't know if you had it
when you were with the giants.
Are--Are you gonna have it
in the niners' locker room?
We had it with the giants
throughout the playoff run,
then we went to indianapolis
to play in the super bowl.
Those guys--they loved it.
Guys were sharing.
Like, the--the bottles,
you drink half and another guy
drink half of that.
Like, it--It--It was crazy.
You guys had a big ol' comeback,
right? The second half?
Yeah.
Was that the difference?
So I couldn't tell if that
was the reason why...
no, I know. I know.
I know. I know.
We went and won.
But they loved it.
I like that.
You're not giving us the B.S.,
but you believe in it.
I like that.
Tell us about the economics
of the business--
what you're sales are, how
business is going in general.
I have invested $75,000.
It cost me $1.10 to make
per bottle,
But those costs will be
significantly dropped
once I reach certain benchmarks
in quantity.
What do you sell it
to the wholesaler for?
$1.80.
Ugh. I hate it.
So you're making 70 cents margin
but still, it's not horrible.
And what does it retail for?
$3.99.
Well, good margin for them,
bad margin for you.
Tania, you realize
that your distributors are
making more money than you?
Well...
that's upside down.
That's what life is like
in hell.
You have to make more money
than they do. That's crazy.
You gotta pay your dues
in whatever business you're in.
You're not worried about it
because you're not on
the P&l side.
You're taking it off the top.
I as an investor would be very
concerned about those margins.
That's how
I get my money back.
In what kind of retailers?
We're in
all the delis and markets
that flooded in manhattan,
and also big box retailers.
You told us
you're in 3,000 stores
how much have you sold
in the last year?
Okay, we've been in the--
um, on the market
for just about
three months now.
We've done $126,000
in sales.
$120,000 in sales
in 3 months?
Yes.
I'm surprised, Tania, you--You
haven't been slaughtered yet.
Somehow you've survived.
Maybe the right partnerships.
I don't know. But you are not
worth $1.7 million
under any scenario. You've got
way too much to prove.
Good luck to you,
but I'm out.
Yep.
Here's what I see.
You've got a great idea,
great product.
You've got a great angle because
you got Brandon and New York.
Now he's gonna go out
to san Francisco.
That's not the challenge.
The challenge is never the first
act. It's like the nfl.
The nfl stands for
"not for long"
for a lot of people.
He's absolutely correct.
It's the same thing
in your business here.
The hard part is
the second act.
After the newness wears off,
after someone tries
to knock you off
and comes out with
super PRO-NRG,
then that's the hard part.
I hate businesses where
everybody and their brother
is trying to get in.
To me, if you're looking
where everybody else is looking,
you're looking
in the wrong spot.
I try to go
where people aren't.
So for that reason,
I have to say I'm out.
Okay.
Tania, you've failed to be clear
as to what the product was
after a lot of conversation.
Even when I look
at your packaging here,
it's even confusing
as a stand-Alone.
And I just wanna
make a note about Brandon.
I don't think you utilize him
well at all.
He's great.
The first time he engaged me
was when he told
his locker room story.
I'm picturing this pitch
all over,
and him coming out
and him starting it and saying,
"I was in my locker room--"
"and we were losing
the super bowl.
Then I hit the pro-'Nurg'."
Yeah. (chuckles)
"Wham!"
wham! Anything like that!
"We win!"
PRO-"nurg."
Pro-"energy"!
but because of the confusion
of your message alone,
which it you've gotta clean up,
I'm out.
Tania, you've done
an amazing job.
I don't think we've ever had
anybody out here
that's been in business
for the amount of time you have
with the distribution
that you have.
I mean, it's unbelievable.
You must be the best salesperson
we've ever met.
But, you know, my concern is,
besides the cash,
I think you need somebody
who understands this space.
For me,
it's an energy drink space.
It's just not something
I wanna compete in.
You know, for that reason, um...
don't say it. (chuckles)
I'm out.
(sighs)
okay.
Yeah.
Way it is.
Tania, there are
four sharks out.
Only one remains--Daymond.
Okay, Daymond.
Listen, you know,
my challenges with this,
I think is what all the sharks
have--Have vocalized.
Uh, you know,
very high valuation,
such a-a hard market
to get into.
But the good side of it
is that, um,
I just invested in a-a bunch
of crossfits.
I'm starting to understand
how much people want
this type of stuff.
I forbid you to pay
$1.7 million for this.
I forbid you.
I'm gonna give you
$250,000 for 30%,
but that is contingent
on me taking it to
a protein and supplement
company
that I have
a partnership with--
It's called badass--
And closing a deal
with them.
And, Brandon,
I need you in the room
telling that super bowl story,
to help us sell this thing.
I got you.
Just in case you hadn't notice,
shark Daymond has cut
your value in half.
Mm-hmm.
I realize that,
but I need his know-How, how to
navigate through those meetings.
Is that a "Yes"?
that's a "Yes," Daymond.
All right!
Congratulations.
I hope it's not the energy drink
making me do this.
(all laugh)
You jumped up
pretty fast there.
I did. I did.
All right. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
(Daymond and Barbara)
Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
See ya, guys.
(Kevin) I think you need
to reposition this.
I don't think anybody
understands what it is.
Anybody who works out
understands completely.
♪♪♪
Hi, sharks. I'm Mona Weiss...
and I'm Scott Shields.
And our company is Eco Nuts.
We are here seeking $175,000
for a 15% stake
in our company.
Eco Nuts is a line of
eco-friendly cleaning products
packaged with little
to no plastic.
Now I know what you're thinking.
"Oh, it's another
green Cleaning company."
But Eco Nuts
are totally different.
Most of our products
are certified organic
and are based on this.
This is our secret weapon.
It's an organic berry
from the himalayas
that naturally produces a soap.
It's called a soapberry,
or soap nut,
thus our name Eco Nuts.
You can use these berries
for laundry
by placing
four to five of 'em...
place them into the wash bag
like so,
directly in your machine.
When it comes in contact
with the water,
it releases a natural soap
as it gets shaken around,
which can do your laundry.
This jar of water is gonna
represent your washing machine.
I'm gonna place in one.
It makes soap. Isn't that cool?
(laughs)
(Mona) You can... (laughs)
It's still solid.
Well, it does--You can
reuse these up to ten times.
(sharks) Ah.
This box here does
a year's worth of laundry,
and it replaces ten bottles
of detergent.
And now is the perfect time
to invest.
Americans spend over $70 billion
a year on cleaning products,
and with your help, we can
help take a bite out of it
and help save the planet.
What do you say, sharks?
You with us?
But why is it the perfect time
to invest?
Well, we were first
to the mainstream market,
and now, uh,
we are going to be everywhere.
We've managed to capture about
90% of the soapberry market
thus far by branding it--
(chuckles)
There's a soapberry market?
There is a soapberry market
out there, believe it or not.
Okay.
Scott, what percentage?
Uh, 90%
in less than 3 years.
(Daymond) How big is
the soapberry market?
(Kevin) How big is it annually?
It's--in the U.S., it's right
around about $1 million.
So you have $900,000
in sales?
No. I...
(sharks laugh)
I walked into that one,
didn't I?
Let's do the math.
(Mark) OHH!
All right. Wait.
Hold--Hold on a second.
Wait. I caught you
with your mouth open. I got it.
Let's uh--
why don't you put
one of those soapberries
in your mouth right now?
Can we--can we just go back
to Scott's point
of 90% market share?
Yeah. Okay.
(Mark) Yeah.
How much does that equate to
in terms of sales?
90% of market share--
for us, what it equates to is,
last year,
we did about $100,000.
This year, we're already
on track to do over $250,000.
Can I see a sample?
Why, yes.
Absolutely.
Got a tray for you
right here.
I love Mona.
Mona is a champ.
Are these the nuts?
Yes.
(Kevin) Thank you, Mona.
You're welcome.
Are the two of you married?
Not yet. We're working on it.
No. We're engaged.
(Kevin speaks indistinctly)
(mark and Daymond) AW!
(Robert) congratulations!
We--Oh, don't congratulate me.
We've been engaged
for five years.
(all laugh)
Scott, you animal!
Mona, Mona, let me ask you this.
Why does a guy stay engaged
for fives years?
Why would he do that?
We're not using the investment
money to get married,
but we need to bring
our business to the next level
so that we can get married.
(laughs)
Let's say this market
takes off.
You're assuming your brand
Eco Nuts
will maintain its dominance.
Oh, first of all,
we have a proprietary
sterilization process.
And we came up with this
because while he and I were
in our living room
Originally sorting berries,
and we had people who were
helping us out sorting berries,
we were all getting sick.
And we--we decided there must be
something going on with these,
so we sent them off to a lab,
and we found that they had
stuff on them.
Stuff on nuts. Imagine that.
So you had to get your nuts
sterilized?
So you found that they had
monkey poop on them?
(Scott) Exactly.
Everybody needs
their nuts sterilized.
And if you look into--
Basically, if you look into
trying Different
sterilization practices,
you'll find it's very difficult
to get one that is for organic.
I'm gonna ask you
an important question.
You have 90% of the market.
You say you've done
about $250,000.
You're, uh, asking for a little
over $1 million valuation.
Uh-huh.
Give me the valuation,
why you came up with that.
It--It's based on the fact that
every year we've been
in business,
we have doubled and tripled
our sales.
We started our company
with $1,000.
Now we didn't put anymore money
into it for over a year.
We made $10,000.
Our next year, we made $40,000.
Then we saw the business
was going somewhere.
We put it--
but you're still not making
any money.
We've--We've done over $100,000
this year already.
How did you secure
your customer base?
Well, I'm a social media ninja.
(laughs)
Ah.
We've got more fans on facebook
than you do, Barbara.
Well, I'm insulted.
And I'm out.
(Mark laughs)
There you go, Barbara!
Oh, don't be out yet!
(laughs) I'm only kidding.
(Mark) Barbara?
(Robert) WHOA!
No, no, no. I'm not.
Okay.
Look at that.
(laughs)
(Kevin) The market is
so small right now.
And what you've got--Like,
$1 million in sales in the U.S.
Means a tremendous amount
of education
that's to occur before
people who do laundry
are gonna start buying nuts.
It's gonna be a tough haul.
I'm not saying
it's impossible.
you're not the best.
It's just that
your company today
is not worth over $1 million.
It just isn't. You're not making
enough money yet.
You're not even married yet.
For $175,000,
I'd probably have to own
all of this company right now.
I'm out.
So you say you're number one
in the market.
I'm trying to understand it.
Shouldn't have said that, Scott.
Right?
You said that the market is
$1 million...
it--It's not $1 million.
He messed up.
Domestically.
How do you not know
the numbers, Scott?
Right.
Hold on, Robert. Robert.
You shouldn't be making
these mistakes
and these assumptions.
I'm out.
Who do we have left here?
Robert?
You gotta know the numbers.
You can't come out and say,
"I own 90% of the market,"
and it turns out
you might own 10%, 15%.
I would like to
get into this business
because I do think
it's gonna grow.
At $175,000,
what possible offer
could I give you
that's reasonable from
a pure numbers perspective?
It's--It's not
a $1.2 million business today.
$175,000
for... 50%?
Would you consider that?
I'd consider it but I wouldn't
take it, unfortunately.
I mean...
just from what we've done...
(speaks indistinctly)
Well, you better be working
16 hours a day on our business,
like we do.
Sorry. What did you say?
♪♪♪
Two sharks are out.
Mona and Scott have one offer
on the table from Robert--
$175,000 for a 50% stake.
But Mona has questioned what
Robert will bring to the table
for such a high stake
in the business.
Just from what we've done...
(speaks indistinctly)
Well, you better be working
16 hours a day on our business,
like we do.
Sorry. What did you say?
(laughs) I said,
"you better be working
16 hours a day on our business,
like we do."
(laughs) For that kind of...
for that kind of money.
Oh--Oh, no, Mona. I worked
24 hours a day on my business
so I could have the privilege
of sitting up here
and listening
to people like you.
I'm out.
Okay.
Guys, I'll get right to
the point.
I think your marketing's
horrible.
There's nothing that's gonna
demonstrate to me
that your product is
any different than the others.
You're using berries
to do your clothes.
We sterilize ours.
But that's the point.
You may sterilize them,
but there's nothing there
that tells me
that you do that.
You've completely left out
your greatest differentiation.
Well, just the branding
and the look
of the boxes alone--
When you look at how
traditionally in the marketplace
where it's sold--
When I look at the boxes,
I'm gonna know
they're sterilized nuts?
At our size, advertising out
there in front of everybody...
"Oh, look.
Here's this, here's that.
Here's what we do
so differently"...
until we're actually large
enough to truly have
our big, big place--
You're giving me excuses.
Excuses are worthless.
I'm giving you a very solid
and valid reason
of how we managed to protect
ourselves in the business...
your packaging sucks.
Run rabid with dogs
and manage to climb our way up
to be number one.
Congratulations.
And we will not
be brought down,
even if another larger company
comes in--
You know what?
When you're done patting
yourself on the back,
you should look at
your marketing and say,
"the message this big board
sends me is not gonna
educate me on the fact that you
have a differentiated product."
You've completely
left it out,
and now you've left me out.
I'm out.
Okay.
Hi, sharkette.
Well, let me tell you,
the best part about
your pitch today
is you are
such a good couple.
It only take an hour
to get married.
Oh, my lord.
I think the Eco Nuts name
is great,
but beyond that,
I don't think you present
the product well at all.
Not really.
I'm out.
Well, thank you.
Well, thank you very much
for letting us show everything.
(Kevin)
Wait. Wait. Wait a minute.
I also agree with Barbara
that you did
a genuinely terrible job.
But she really moved me
with something she said.
And I haven't done this before
on "Shark Tank,"
but I'm willing to do it today
because I am Mr. Wonderful.
Do you want me to
marry you now?
(all laugh)
Can you marry us?
Of course I can.
I'm Mr. Wonderful.
My parents would kill me.
I'm sorry. Then you leave
with nothing.
Well, get them on the line.
All right, guys.
Well, good luck.
(Mark) Good luck, guys.
Bye!
Scott, marry that woman.
Ah! (laughs)
I will!
Let me do it for you now!
(sharks laugh)
When Scott said that we had
a 90% share
of a $1 million market,
I was thinking,
oh, no. That's not what it is.
I didn't wanna, like, stop him
right then and there on air
'cause I didn't want
to embarrass him.
But, like, you know,
I-I didn't wanna...
it's okay. I do a great job
embarrassing myself. (laughs)